all right what we're gonna start off
with here is that homepage what you
first get when you first visit your own
profile with the new profile and up here
of course you have this neat little tour
so I'm actually going to take you guys
through this tour for the first time
with you it gives you a quick little
slideshow of some random photos I've
been tagged in you can see they're
mostly frisbee stuff and that gives you
an idea of what the cover photo will
look like which I'll get to in a second
and it says you can start with your
cover I'll upload that in a second we
hit next and it'll go ahead and bring
you to the everything in one place bar
this is the kind of place like it says
here where you find info and apps and
stuff go ahead and hit next here and you
can view all your activity this is kind
of a personal privacy log thing where
you can change what people see and what
they don't see then we can rediscover
all of our top stories by scrolling down
infinitely far or just exploring it's
two pane layout the two pane layout is
really the newest thing about this and
last but not least you can hover over a
story and click the star to expand it to
be the full widescreen or just you know
edit who would be able to see the post
or delete it entirely so that's
basically the mini tour they give you so
I'll go ahead and scroll back up to the
top here you can see nothing else really
has changed you still have that the chat
on the right-hand side and of course
still it's a little bit blurred because
of privacy but then again you might want
to go ahead and check out the link in
the description to get this either way
I'm going to go ahead and add a cover
and I'm going to choose from my photos
because I just picked a random photo I
happen to have actually I want to upload
a photo because I have it on my desktop
we'll hit upload a photo but you can use
a photo that's already on Facebook and
I'll take the one called cover and open
it and we'll go ahead and see if it
looks good here it's not a picture of
myself but the one that's already in my
profile picture is here and we can
change that so we can drag to reposition
that which is pretty sweet good and Save
Changes and it looks like the cover was
uploaded pretty nicely so that looks
pretty cool with the bokeh of the lens
that I took the photo with so it looks
pretty good here's all the information
stuff this is the stuff that usually
appears in the top bar over Facebook now
go ahead and check out the way you can
customize this basically the way it
works is if you hit that drop down arrow
right there
you can add apps then more things from
those apps will appear here so I'll go
ahead and click friends for example and
you can check out all the different
friends I have in there blurred photos
but like then again you get to see that
it's laid out in a very photo centric
way there's
search bar you can edit your friends
find your friends things like that I'll
go back here you can also hit that
photos button right here to view a very
similar layout of all your photos or a
like button here where you can view all
the likes again in a photo array and
I'll hit that drop down now it should be
working basically you have all your
subscriptions and if you get that plus
button you can add apps to be more in
that spot so if I hit SoundCloud I am
connected to SoundCloud through Facebook
so now I guess whenever I listen to a
new song on SoundCloud that app will
show up there are things like that and
if I click on that you'll get a photo
layout of all the songs I listen to on
soundcloud so that's pretty cool
but the main attraction here is the the
actual timeline you of course have all
this information you can scroll down
stalker mode here go home use certain
dates and if you hit born you actually
go go all the way back to my born to
here which is December 3rd 1983 you can
add a photo to commemorate that or to
represent that and of course I could
like my cell yeah I'm gonna like myself
being born that that's pretty cool so we
go scroll back up to now but as you know
as you scroll further down the timeline
it gets more and more and more
summarized so it basically summarizes
what you've done already so I'm gonna
scroll really far down just for kicks
cuz most of the stuff you don't care
about and you can see I wasn't really
very active on Facebook during the year
2008 or any time for that matter between
2008 and the year I was born but that's
a basically overview of the new timeline
if you guys have any questions please
feel free to leave a comment or you can
of course personal message me I answer
all the comments and personal messages
on YouTube of course you're probably
wondering how to post a status update
that is down here on the left hand side
in this box you can put what's on your
mind you can check in and if you do have
enough check-ins you can view all of
your check-in locations on a map and see
where you've been during your whole life
so that's really cool this really makes
it like a personal blog you can really
just keep track of your whole life here
and really get facebook all your
information and that's basically it if
you have any questions like I said go
ahead and leave a comment and I will
talk to you guys in the next video
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
later
peace
you